>> DICMAR (ph): Hi, my name is Sander Dicmar
(ph).
>> CRESPO: My name is Arturo Crespo.
>> PRECK (ph): I’m Devash Preck (ph).
>> COLEMAK (ph): And I’m Mark Colemak (ph).
>> All: And we work on Android Market.
>> COLEMAK (ph): And I’m going to show you
how to find things on Android Market. Android
Market has several options for browsing content
that you can download. We have the featured
gallery appeared at the top which is icons
of applications that you can install, and
we also have categories of applications and
games. Going into the applications, it shows
you different subcategories or you can look
at all the applications. And from here, you
can look at--you can browse by popularity,
of what’s popular and really not so popular,
and also by date to see what’s the latest
things that have been uploaded.
>> DICMAR (ph): And I’m going to show you
how to search and install an application through
the Android Market. I’d like to install
an application that tracks my carbon foot
print on a daily basis so I can click on the
search pattern in our Android Market. Enter
the search query carbon, and market shows
me all the applications that have carbon in
their description. I can then click on this
application called Ecorio, I can view the
details for the application and once I’m
suitably pleased, I can install the application.
Market now shows me the permissions that are
required for this application. Some of the
permissions that are required are a network
communication and knowing my location. Once
I’ve approved these permissions, I can click
on okay, and market starts the download and
installed in the background. I can now go
back to market home, browse to any other application
that I’d like. I like this game called Bonsai
Blast and I can start the install of this
simultaneously. Now what market is doing is
downloading and installing both applications
in the background. Once the download and installation
succeeds, I receive a notification on the
notification bar. I can pull the notification
window and click on Ecorio which has been
just installed.
>> CRESPO: Next I’m going to show you how
you can find all the application you have
downloaded, and rate one of them. So I can
go and click on my downloads and I get the
list of all application including the two
that we just downloaded. So, after I'm in
this screen, I can go to Ecorio and now it
can read the application again but I can also
write the application. So, you can go click
and rate it, and here we have our screen working,
give it a score of between one to five stars.
So let’s give it four stars, above average.
I could also post a comment telling people
more about this application. If I have more
serious concerns about the application, I
can go and flag the application. And I can
write what are my concerns. In this case,
there is no, there are no concerns so we’ll
go back.
>> PRECK (ph): Finally, here’s how to uninstall
an application. First, I go to my downloads,
and I click on Android says, then I press
uninstall. It will tell me that I’m about
to uninstall this application from my phone
and I click okay. And then I can give a reason
for why I uninstalled it. If it’s malicious,
I can report it here, but this is just a game
I don't want to play. So, I’ll choose it.